Michael Bay is no stranger to battle
sequences but the filmmaker explained to
Fandango that the fifth entry in this
Saga contains the most arduous action
sequence in his career Bay openly
admitted that he'd never done a period
era medieval battle involving Knights
before he shot the opening fight
sequence of Transformers the last night
most of Bay's big action sequences
involved Car Chasers and elements
discernably attached to the modern world
suddenly being thrust into the landscape
and battled tactics of a period era
setting was an incredibly daunting task
for Bay Bay also had personal problems
informing why the sequence was so
challenging as his dog Bone Crusher who
had appeared in several previous
Transformers films died the night before
he shot this sequence the loss of a pet
impacted Bay profoundly however with so
many practical tools Bay had to buckle
down and direct a battle sequence like
no other in his filmography the result
was a set piece that took three days to
shoot but did leave Bay feeling
incredibly accomplished once it was
finished